but you didn't say unto me
you didn't do unto me well that's what I
was thinking like
I just don't like you no more
what is it like knowing the entire
nation of Ireland is pulling for you
because I've seen the ads they're
literally booking tourism now off of
this are they really yeah Brendan tell
me about it yeah well it's really great
because we did this well it doesn't
surprise me yeah we went to Bruges and
that Bruce went up 30 after the movie in
terms of Tourism so they were remember
the repenting up signs even before we
left Bruce yeah so like for this I'm not
surprised that they're out of uh yeah no
that doesn't that does make sense but
I'm thrilled it gives a bit of a lift to
everybody I think you know when when the
team does well so uh did I used to hear
about it yeah I'm gonna say this again
because I I did tell you after 13 hours
and then I think I've seen him randomly
on a couple of things I've been like
championing I'm like I'm gonna see you
in February at the Oscars and this one
didn't believe it but I have to ask you
what was it like that morning was
somebody calling you were you staying
away from it or were you like I need to
know the morning of denominations yeah
um I got a text earlier that day from
Kerry and she said what are you doing
are you gonna go to bed ahead if you're
gonna wait and see if it happens that
your publicist will call you I think
I'll go to bed maybe and I said well
there's a few coming over to my house do
you want to pop by so five o'clock in
the morning knock on the door there she
wasn't her pajamas I had my youngest boy
was with me two sisters a brother-in-law
and Carrie and we watch it live and it
was just we're not even agreeing to
treat it with light but it's just a
moment in time and it's a really lovely
moment and so many people work their
asses off in this film and so to be part
of this film that meant so much to so
many of us in front of and behind the
camera and then now as you say it means
something to the people at home in our
country because I'm getting texts from
my mates saying you know everyone's
watching and we're all cheering you on
and it's just it's so weird because you
would think you're supposed to get a big
head from it but you get the opposite
it's deeply humbling like it's deeply
humbling maybe a little bit of a big
head but it's it's just uh lovely
because what's humbling is anytime you
feel a sense of connection the whole
thing is supposed to be about connection
storytelling isn't it whether you write
a story or whether we do it with a
paintbrush and a canvas or you you put
on a play are you act in the film you're
trying to connect to your fellow that
you're in front of you know the audience
so to connect like this film seems to
have is just it's beautiful but anyway
that was the morning what about you sir
were you surrounded by the family you
got a few actors in your family so I'm
sure you were working the next day I was
working the next day I didn't already
call I was working on Joker two and so I
had to get up at five o'clock anyway so
I kind of uh I needed I needed to get
some sleep and uh so Danica Smith across
there hiding in the corner so I'm gonna
phone you whatever at whatever time it
is so four o'clock in the morning I got
this this call and I said well if you're
ringing it better be good news
and uh so it was kind of bizarre and
thrilling to wake up it was good because
I wasn't all stressed out a 10 started
thinking about it or Anthony I just I
needed to sleep
and it's got a nice way to go to work
you know what I mean yeah and what did
they say work the hometown hero took a
while to kind of bleed in you know
because it wasn't that long after but
only so not everybody had known and seen
it so I'm there going hmm saying nothing
and then people said so it was great so
yeah nice phone call to get I just
realized this are y'all swapping notes
on the new DC like like I mean like
literally you're both in you're both in
DC films you're looking like Dapper
dance together y'all are really like
coming as like the Irish beetles
[Laughter]
Barry's Barry's my Joker yeah and then
I'm Joaquin as his yeah I start doing
the penguin show in three two three
weeks or something it's kind of crazy
too to think about you guys from in
Bruce to now like yeah you all already
had incredible careers before then but I
really do feel with both of you that was
the beginning of of different chapters
in a lot of ways Island Bridge was it
was a special one really
um and definitely uh the way it kind of
um became a cultish film with having
been a massive box office success or
anything like that was was deeply
satisfying because it was I'd say
irritating for the producers but it kind
of bled in
um beautifully in a way that people
really respected for so when they were
talking to you it was coming from what
they really bought into the film and I'm
not sure what it would do I I don't know
what those these things do at
career-wise I I suppose I live in Dublin
all the time so there would have been a
little bit more high high profile over
here for me but you had as higher
profile as you could wish for anyway
um I guess I don't know I think people
maybe were looking for some of our work
with a different intent after this you
know what I mean that they weren't they
were looking would have specific for you
to look at something that had a degree
of intelligence in the writing and the
way Martin McDonough stuff is it's very
hard to actually kind of
compartmentalize so it kind of brought
people into new areas maybe yeah
are you Queen of the most powerful
nation in the world and my entire family
is gone
have I not given everything
what does it mean to you to be back here
and to be back here again leading up all
black cast that is also Oscar nominee oh
it's phenomenal it just means that um
you know that you've been consistent and
that you persevered yeah continue to
work hard and and to show up what's been
the best moment for you on this sort of
like Oscar run this time uh what's been
a moment that you really sort of cherish
about it oh let's see let's see well of
course uh at the Golden Globes you know
seeing the the love and support of my
husband and everyone else seeing that as
well as he you know videotaped that
moment like you could never find it
anywhere else in the world
so uh that was that was pretty typical
of him but um it's it's nice yeah for
folks that don't know your husband goes
down in history is the most supportive
husband ever because when you were ever
on stage he was right there with the
camera making sure he captures every
moment and I know he Prides himself on
that Mr Courtney B Vance it really does
feel like the film is continued to be
honored but so much of it was in a
grieving place this time around and so
much of it was related to what you guys
had going on with Chadwick what do you
hope it sort of leaves in addition to
the Legacy that you guys were already
building upon when you came back when
you have to go through things as you
know as
oh challenging is that the the grief the
depth of grief that we felt there it was
an opportunity to really dig deep within
yourselves and to create something
lasting and beautiful and something that
would pay tribute to him and to
um the Legacy that he he helped to the
success that he helped to to lead us
lead us all to and I really feel that
you know sitting next to him during the
first Panther day to day to day every
morning that this is something that he
would be proud of in a very beautiful
way he still isn't he is very much a
part of of this moment and still of this
journey as it continues as today and as
it continues to go forward whatever that
might look like stop saying nothing I'm
saying nothing I know nothing in
whatever way
whatever way thank you thank you you
made such history the very first MCU
actor to ever be nominated for role and
of all the superhero movies the only
non-villain to be oscar-nominated you
made such a non-villain enough really a
superhero yeah exactly just a regular
woman a queen a queen yes such a
phenomenal achievement but there's been
some great movies this year I would just
ask you which other films besides your
work in this one did you particularly
admire this year I did enjoy Elvis I
enjoyed till
um yeah very much I enjoyed the Banshees
of Anna shearin and of course everything
everywhere yeah so yeah
I wish to promote you Mr Presley
are you ready to fly how much ready to
fly it has to make this entire thing so
Bittersweet with the recent news and I
just I have to ask you as a human how it
feels to have to try and celebrate this
knowing that there is literally yeah
just such a cloud in the absence of Lisa
Marie yeah
I mean it's hard to sort of put into
words
we all had the great Fortune of getting
to spend so much time with Lisa Marie
and with with her family and she and I
got to spend such special moments
together you know that and we both sort
of filled certain voids in each other's
lives you know and um
and so it Bittersweet is the word that
I've been using as well and because I
know how much this film meant to her and
I know you know that's that moment of
getting to celebrate with her at the
Golden Globes and how much that it means
to us and how much it meant to her and
and yeah and it is I had a really hard
time celebrating for a while after and
Jerry Schilling actually he texts me and
said you know Lisa would want you to
enjoy this time and so I've I've been
trying to just carry her Legacy through
through all uh that we're doing with you
know talking about the film now and and
also just not just us but I think
everybody being there for their family
right now and this time is really
important and and and realizing that
grief is not something that is like a
car crash that happens and then goes
away but it's it lasts for a long time
so I think just everybody continuing to
send them love and support is is really
vital in this time I don't know what
happened she was in a car accident on
the causeway
I had about a lot of medication got a
medication like don't shoot yourself in
the head kind of medication
okay what was it like that morning to
hear your name called you should ask the
random white man in my building that was
in the elevator when I got the
information I screamed at this poor man
um because I screamed at him like you
know he stuck on this elevator and he
sees me scream and he's like what
happened and I'm like there's nothing
for an Oscar and he's like for what
movie I'm like who cares
I don't know uh but it was nice because
what it felt like is that it felt like
he won two you know like we never met
each other and he was just so incredibly
happy for me and I feel like that's what
this whole thing has been it feels like
this nomination feels like everyone won
something it's like the nomination in
and of itself feels like a win
um because there's been so many people
who have held this vision for me who
have you know would tell me all the time
like well it's a matter of time and just
like you you're like okay well you know
whatever I just want to show up and do
great work you know that's what that's
my job but to really hear it from people
and contemporaries that I've admired and
and people that have been with me along
the way to really be like yeah like it's
very exciting and I'm like you know it's
bigger than me it's not just mine you
know it's shared so I don't know how I
feel about it like I'll sit down
sometimes
um and just like take a deep breath and
go because I you know I'm free and then
it'll hit me and I'm like oh right you
know like
it that happened
um but it's truly I don't know it's an
out-of-body experience it feels good I'm
in a great class I'm amongst great
people also saying that Angela bass is
up there is a win uh you know what I'm
saying so it just it feels like a big
win already
um so whatever happens in March really
isn't a big deal um because I already
feel like I won really honestly just
being here what was it like when you got
to talk to uh your director and Miss
Jennifer Lawrence about this because
it's both producer and director I know
as much as they were happy for the film
and your journey to make it I know they
were equally as happy about the flowers
Jennifer Lawrence would say it after
every take honestly annoyingly so
she's like you're gonna get nominated
for Oscar for this and then just walk
away and I'm like what are you talking
about and so like months of that
honestly months of that and she you know
and and I just never you know like
Jennifer is we just so I was like okay
whatever shut up like whatever but the
fact that all of them
had a feeling and held that you know
from from from day one they honestly
always supported that
Lila nugabauer I cannot say enough about
her and her vision and her support and
hers a person because I've always wanted
to be there and in some capacity to work
with her creatively and when I got the
call to do this movie it just there was
no such thing as not doing it because
Lila was at the helm of it to be able to
come to a project like this to watch her
get her flowers in a way you know by
directing this
first feature with you know Academy
Award winner Jennifer Lawrence and to
make a nominee out of me is really
really wonderful like it just it's
something and so when I got I mean like
it it was just another excuse for them
to scream at me like I told you so you
know uh like
um so it was truly just I don't know it
feels so great to know that they held
that vision and believed in it um before
I even had any idea not only do you have
your first Oscar nominations but so many
of your eternals crew and then if you
also want to go ahead and take it way
back your Yale grad friends that have
also made a way for this it does feel
like a bit of a family affair what's
really cool about what we do and I was
saying this to somebody else I was like
you you hope that at some point in in
coming up because we were all we were
all not like the other kids right like
there was something like we were all
those kind of just
crunchy kids doing something different
you know and you kind of hope that at
some point you find each other like you
you hope that you're enough of a channel
to actually attract those things to you
and it really has felt like that I
remember doing eternals with Barry who
like when I tell you Barry he is one
like we were inseparable like that was
my G and
you could just feel that this was
something different it was something new
just because of who the people were and
to be in that space and time and you
just go with it you know like even with
Colin Farrell like when we did widows
there was an immediate connection
between us of wanting to I mean tether
it's a tether and so like I feel like
all of this is just a reflection of that
and it's just really great to be amongst
your peers that's what I'm saying it
feels like a community of peers and
contemporaries that are just out here
wanting to create and people are
recognizing that and giving us you know
our accolades so it's great I mean it's
it's I'm in a great class I'm amongst a
great number
um and we're all witches I don't know if
y'all know that but we're all witches so
this was inevitable um
[Music]
no why there's this feeling once you
leave for your show that you don't
totally belong there again thinking back
to like then when the film was first
coming out did you think you'd be here
oh no I didn't think that would be I was
hoped in some alternate universe that it
may happen but I don't think there was
any
true expectation of us
actualizing yeah what was that first
morning like for you because I know you
were still in the middle of your place
yeah and it was in the middle it's like
weird timing for everything so where who
was the person that told you did you get
the publicist call were you watching no
I was I had planned a meeting that
morning that I had hoped would kind of
move through the nomination so I would
just come out of the meeting and
find out or know or the meeting ended
like bang on time I was back in my flask
I was like I'm just going to stick them
on watch that on my phone then went and
did the play in the evening
it's crazy one of the great parts of
this whole Oscar tour is you're kind of
in a class with a whole bunch of other
nominees and I saw you in the Daniels so
I'm gonna have something y'all got to
spend time together I bumped into them
at the governor's Awards and just
freaked out the fact that they'd seen
the film then got to like
share a interview with them it's pretty
insane I love that film and from my
brief interactions with them I they seem
like the most generous man yeah is there
somebody else as the part of this sort
of uh I guess the Oscar season that
you've gotten to see their film that you
particularly enjoyed or or somebody that
you got to meet I mean there's a lot of
really great names on this one time this
time around I mean like to be nominated
in a category with Colin as as a young
Irish actor watching him for years is
something that I take like
great pride in Michelle Williams I don't
know her at all but I idolize her work
so they're the two that jump into spring
into mind your young co-star she's also
been getting a ton of accolades too
especially in the young performers what
has that been like to sort of see this
process through her eyes I mean when I
was making it a kind of weirdly felt
like that was inevitable I the minute
she stepped on set the minute she was in
front of camera I was like you're a star
and she is a star that uh don't work
with animals or kids thing is probably
true for some people but I
would do it again in a heartbeat if the
actor was as good as Frankie as which
maybe is the key piece of information